[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice chris hogan ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
is my co-host today our phone number is
triple eight
eight two five five two two
five we are going to take a second
though and
pause on the phone calls and um
just pay honor to uh our friend rush
limbaugh who passed away this
morning and um
there are very few people in this world
that create
an entire industry elvis
you know the king of rock and roll even
the beatles followed elvis
you know and um rush created dark radio
as we know it there were a few people
doing it odds and ends here or there
but uh the first person to do of scale
for sure and uh in the process of
those number of decades becomes an
american icon
and and um uh
very interesting guy i got to spend a
little time with him a few times
and um obviously i was a little bit star
struck
and so whether you agreed with his
politics
or not uh for god's sake some of you out
there have some
class today it's hard for some of you
but you ought to have a little class
i mean if someone you completely
disagree with and you hate their message
passes away and you can't mama used to
say if you can't say nothing nice don't
say nothing at all so that's right it's
a good plan for some of you just
just shut up but um
uh uh rush created an industry i mean he
and some of the guys were working with
him in the early days
took am radio and it was on life support
and brought it back to life
uh to the point that am radio stations
which were
you know prior to that almost didn't
exist in the ratings books
uh became the number one uh rated show
or our station
in many many cities on am talk you know
am talk radio did that
wow and uh and it was him that uh blazed
a trail
and you know he blazed the trail because
there's so many people that came along
after him that wanted to be him that's
right there's so many rush wannabes on
the air
out there um and uh or people that just
stepped into the same space
with their own thumbprint uh but some of
them not very original some of them very
original
and a lot of them are friends uh and um
but uh uh you know very here's
here's what it takes to do what he did
uh you have to have an
unbelievable intellect which he did uh
his his critical thinking skills are
unbelievable and
his sense of humor the one thing he does
that so many don't do
when he's discussing stuff is not only
to make fun of himself but
i made fun of himself but he um
he's just dead come funny uh well it was
and it's just um it's hard to think
about past tense get my
get my grammar correct here but um
his ability to deliver that and his
ability to deliver
uh thought-provoking things and for
those of us that are
consider ourselves conservatives he put
words to things we were already thinking
and feeling
and uh it really wasn't like what he was
saying was new
just like me you know and you chris we
don't see anything new get out of debt
your grandmother said that that's right
you know it's nothing new but we've just
done it with a panache
and in a way and with enough volume that
it's touched millions of lives and
certainly he did
um and so iconic
iconic guy uh behind the scenes uh an
introvert
ah i didn't know that yeah i'm not a not
a uh
you would think as loud and uh
gregarious as he was on the air that he
would be
that way in a in a cocktail party and he
would just as soon not be
at a cocktail party just soon not be in
a crowd
and a lot of the guys on the radio are
that way a lot of gals and stuff even on
tv
that they're uh you know they they don't
mind the camera they don't mind the
microphone but a crowded room is not
something they want to do
uh i'm unusual in that regard because i
am actually an extrovert but um
i'm louder in those situations than i am
here
just a little bit just a little bit but
he uh um
you know he sets the standard and those
are shoes that won't be filled
uh there'll be a lot of attempts in the
coming weeks for uh all of us in the
business to try to figure out what to do
now
uh because it leaves a gaping hole in
talk radio obviously
but no one will uh people will come
along and do their own version of
whatever they need to do i hope i hope
they don't try to just do rush again
because that'll be a mistake
yeah it would be and uh because it's
impossible yeah well i can tell you i
mean he's definitely an icon
uh bombastic had no fear of giving you
his opinion
uh and like you said critical thinking
skills were unmatched
uh being able to look at both sides but
also tell you what he believed
uh and his feeling and so uh prayers go
out to his family
yeah absolutely and we've reached out to
the team that's around him we know all
of those and around his family and so
forth and um
all of that but you know it is an
interesting thing
to stand back and look at a person whose
uh life was so epic that they literally
created an industry
i mean henry ford created the assembly
line
and thereby the automotive industry
without a doubt
yeah i mean there are people say the car
was invented before henry ford yeah but
no one did it like he did it
i mean there was he took it to scale
there were other people making cars
in their basements and other things but
you know the
mass production line um the ability to
uh you know create a factory
to to make cars and you know the ford
model t's
became the thing everybody after that
was uh
including tesla still trying to catch up
you know and
um so that's what happens and when you
come in and an entire
genre an entire industry is created
around
a person's skill a person's ability and
so forth that's iconic that's iconic and
we've certainly uh the talk radio
portions of the ramsey
solutions business uh have certainly
ridden on the coattails of that
uh had i come out and said i'm gonna do
a a show on the radio and i'm gonna take
phone calls and i'm going to teach
people how to get out of debt before
there was
before the road had been paved by
somebody like rush i have been laughed
out of the building i was already
laughed out of the building several
times anyway but i would have been
really laughed out of the building
and um yeah mammoth mammoth impact
and um and really uh
quality guy again
i didn't agree with everything he said
but i don't agree with anything anybody
says i don't agree with everything hogan
says
so i don't know why you have to go there
but
i expect it i respect it yeah but i mean
you know we don't no one if you if you
have critical thinking skills you don't
agree with any
there's no one you agree with 100
percent no you're right you're
absolutely right
i don't even agree with jesus 100 that
means that means i'm wrong and i got to
turn i got to learn something right
but uh uh so you got to learn and you
know that
but but you know the if you can't
respect
uh the accomplishments the impact
and the quality of that then you're
missing something yeah
whether you agreed with him or not or
whether you agree with his politics or
not well i can tell you this on behalf
of the family
um i would encourage you if your life
was impacted by rush
uh in any way write a letter uh send it
to him
his family it would blow them away to be
able to read those stories and remember
this man in their life amen yeah
i'll rest in peace my friend rest in
peace
[Music]
chris hogan is my co-host today this is
the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five alex is with us in
syracuse new york hi alex how are you
better than i deserve hello mr how are
you just the same sir how can we help
all right well what i'm trying to say
sorry about uh your loss of
mr rush limbaugh i know a lot of people
looked up to him
um my question here is i'm a social
studies teacher in syracuse new york i'm
23 years old
and i'm kind of at the point where i
don't know which questions that i should
be asking
um this particular question is um
about forum 3ds um private pension plans
there's about four different companies
that um i can
set up private pensions with but
i guess my question to you is what
questions should i be asking them
when trying to decide which company to
choose
okay what do you do again i'm a social
studies teacher
a social studies teacher and so your
school system has a 403 b available
and there are four different companies
that you can choose to
fund your 403 b is that what we're
saying
yes sir okay who are they so
i have oil security
aspire and equitable
okay what you're looking for
inside of these companies is what
they're offering for you to put the 403
b
into you're looking for
mutual funds equitable
is most likely life insurance products
stay away from those
they're bad investments okay i don't
know the other companies aspire
equitable and what were the other two
voya financial okay
they probably have mutual funds offered
but you're looking not for an insurance
not for an annuity you're looking for
mutual
funds and so ask them ask each one of
them do you
offer mutual funds as an option and then
if they do you're looking for four types
of mutual funds yep you sure are and
inside of those
you're gonna you're gonna see they're
they're kind of structured uh and when
we talk about being al excuse me being
diversified you wanna
put money we don't want all your eggs in
one basket
and so you're going to look at they're
going to have growth you're going to
have aggressive growth you're going to
have growth in income
but you're also going to have available
international now of those four
types that's what you want to be putting
your money into
as you're investing over the long haul
and so what i would do
is get that information on what they're
offering you
go sit down with one of our smart vester
pros so they can start to help you
understand what's available
and which which program is going to be
the best fit for you in the long haul
but
you are going to hire an investment
professional to help you
you are the owner of this money so
you're not trying to find a guy or gal
just to turn it over to
you're going to work alongside them for
your future
awesome okay okay at 23 years old how
are you
at this point were you taught by your
parents or are you self-taught
so taught by you and mr ramsey
um really honestly but my mom has been a
great support system also
so definitely shout out to mom that is
fantastic
i'm just at this point where people are
telling me things to do
and i just have to pause and be like i
cuz i don't know what i should be asking
so that's what
i'm doing right now and i called the
show before and mr ramsey's helped me um
buy a car
not too long ago oh cool well go to
daveramsey.com there's articles on there
dave has about
questions to ask your investment
professional uh you'll find a wealth of
information there and you can go
right from there with those questions
and go sit down but i can tell you can
save you a lot of heartache and headache
a smartbuster pro is going to be the
person to guide you
and to be able to help you understand
what you're dealing with alex you're
very wise to be asking questions and the
question of what questions to ask is a
good question
uh because the whole thing is do not put
money in something you don't understand
not because i said to hogan said to
anybody else
or your friends for god's sakes put
money in something because you
understand it and what we suggest around
here are the four types of mutual funds
growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
if you can find those with long track
records inside those
403 b companies that are offering to
fund your
your teacher retirement program then
that's where i would put it
but try to stay away from annuities and
try to stay away from
uh insurance life insurance type
products they're all
uh substandard at best uh completely
suck at worst
all right frederick is with us frederick
is in texas
hi frederick how are you i'm doing very
well mr ramsey and mr hogan thanks for
taking the call
our pleasure how can we help uh so i
just had a quick question
on um i'm 22 i'm going to be graduating
from school in about a year and a half
and i'll be graduating graduating with
about 35 000
in student debt and so my my question is
right now should i double down with my
time on school
so that i can you know have the highest
paying income
i could have out of college or should i
you know
pick out a second job or a side job
right now to try to take advantage of
the fact that
you know there's a there's a freeze on
the interest rates for the student loans
and
tackle though that's that's my question
frederick what year are you in school
i so technically i'm a senior but i'm
going to be graduating in five years
because i switched from neuroscience to
finance
five years from now oh no no five years
total so
a year and a half from today so i have
three semesters total
i feel better already yeah okay yeah
and do you have the money set aside to
pay for the remaining of school you have
left
i i do not so it's all student loans so
this like the total like
it'll be all student loans all the way
through and then um
my dad has a good chunk of it in parent
plus and then he put some in my name so
i have 35 total when i graduate
well i'm going to tell you this my
friend i love the spirit of you wanting
to get that debt out of your life but
first and foremost
as dave will tell you the best
investment you can make is in you
and so i would want you to get money set
aside to make sure you're not having to
add
any more student loan debt to this 35
000 right
we're at that limit and so once you have
that in place
and you're paying for your school moving
forward then i want you to turn your
attention to attacking the debt
uh but i don't want you signing any more
of those papers in the financial aid
office they're not your friend
so here's here's the thing there's no
point in paying down your student loans
while you're continuing to borrow
that's filling up the hole with one
shovel and the other hand's digging it
out at the same time
you're just swapping dollars dude does
that make sense no it makes sense
yeah so let's your first goal is work
your butt off and
limit or alleviate the future need for
more borrowing from today forward let's
get out without
any more borrowing that would be goal
one
paying down the student loans that are
the currently there i wouldn't worry
about until after graduation
but your main goal now is to add no more
debt and yes i would work and do that
and i think i heard you say
uh double down on school so i get a
better job
there are very few jobs that pay you
more for
a 4.0 than the for a 3.0
like none
okay i i've been interviewed for jobs
and
interviewed for all kinds of things uh
interviewed in the press and everything
else over the last 40 years of my life
and i can tell you the number of times
someone has asked my gpa when i was in
school
was zero how many times you're yeah i
know you got
i got a master's in finance but no i've
not been asked my gpa you got a master's
in finance nobody asked you what that
was
but when they were in your best-selling
book yeah yeah yeah
but i mean we're not telling him to hold
back no
potential now with this idea that if i'm
going to work my grades are going to
suffer
usually they don't number one no that's
true that's not a
it's not a given and then number two if
you're working
and your grades do suffer a little it's
not gonna mean you don't get a job no
that's true
um and if you get if you're being hired
by people who the difference in a
a 3.5 and a 4.0 or a 3.0 and a 3.5
matters that's not some place you want
to go to work anyway these people are
freaks
you don't really want to work there
there's some strange individuals yeah
aliens yeah one eye in the center
something off star wars i mean really
you don't want that does that
yeah yeah so no i um you get to work
dude
and no more student loans no more bust
your butt and get your butt in class
and no partying quit playing beer pong
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
luke and sarah are with us which can
only mean one thing they're debt-free
way to go guys thank you where do you
guys live
columbus columbus ohio ohio awesome well
welcome to nashville thank you
and you leave ohio and come to nashville
for our one snowstorm of the last five
years
so um now this is our version of global
warming so uh
welcome good to have you and uh how much
debt have you guys paid off
paid off ninety thousand dollars in two
and a half years way to go
excellent and your range of income
during that time sixty thousand to
seventy five thousand
wow wow what kind of debt was the 90 000
it was our house you paid off your house
we're looking at weird people
you guys are cool well done thank you
that's a big deal all right sarah was it
your idea or was it luke's
who started this thing actually it was
me when i first brought it up to him
he was insulted oh he was insulted well
i was kind of the nerd and kind of
working through everything
i kind of did all the finances when she
brought it up to me it was like
am i not doing a good enough job oh so
it took me a few days but with god's
help and kind of smacking me around
i mean he let me know that it was more
about she just wanted to know about the
finances
like so that if something did happen to
me right she could take care of things
okay so what happened from that day
forward uh
well we started the we we got into the
class and oh you didn't went to
financial peace
all right we were introduced to that and
then we started working together and
it was really big shock to me how much
faster things
started working once we were on the same
page yes working together towards things
instead of
me just handling this stuff yes well
you're built like me
and you said you know you're the nerd
you're the you like the numbers
and most of us that are wired that way
we have a tendency to think numbers are
going to fix things
and it's not it's behaviors that fix
things yes and relationships that fix
things the numbers are the result
but it took me a long time to get there
because i wanted to fix everything with
the numbers
a spreadsheet is my life you know so wow
way to go
guys excellent so what's this house
worth uh
about 260. it's all yours
how old are you two weirdos 37
i'm 38. you have paid for a house yeah
that is so wacky
yes i mean you you don't owe a dime nope
no what was the size of the last check
you sent in do you remember ooh
um probably 8 000
that's fantastic uh like a bonus or
something and just popped it huh
yep i love it so well done
yeah so the biggest sacrifice for each
of you what's the biggest thing you gave
up in this journey of
paying off your house my mine was i had
a bunch of little toys and stuff down my
basement
okay that i've saved up throughout you
know my life like what what was one or
one or two of them they're like action
figures
little miniatures oh yeah i sold all of
them all of them what did the what did
the whole kitten caboodle bring
uh i i have no idea at least at least
ten thousand
okay oh wow yeah she had a real car you
had a real collection
yeah down in my basement that's not a
collection you
you had some stuff okay it wasn't just
that stuff i mean we sold that was kind
of
everything that we've sold yeah around
that okay sarah what about you what was
the biggest thing biggest sacrifice
um i would say i was working three jobs
for a while three part-time
jobs i'm down to i would say one and a
half
um so that was a little rough for a
little while um
my photography business really took off
so i was able
to let one of the jobs go and i clean uh
our local church
and uh so it was a little it was rough
during busy season but um we had a goal
we had a goal and we were both um
excited sometimes telling people
that they wanted we wanted they wanted
to do something and ask this to come we
would say no
we're trying to hold down here we got to
we got a goal that we want to hit
and we would just work even harder on it
yeah yeah who are your biggest
cheerleaders
uh probably our family and friends and
our church
he actually leads the fpu group at our
church now and they've been
on board with us ever since and they've
been wonderful and
a lot of great great family and friends
that we have there's nothing that gets
you fired up like
leading it because then you have to do
it yeah that's right
i mean it's not like you can you can
kind of cheat then that's right we saved
our credit cards for
our first class so we could cut them up
on class oh wow
that's cool very cool so to other people
out there that are thinking it's not
possible
right at 37 and 38 years old what would
you tell them
if you stick to the plan and you keep
working at it it can be done
it's it's sacrifice but to me it was
more of
our kids are kind of young so i wanted
to do it when they were younger
and i knew i could sacrifice for a
couple years and then it was like
then we're done yeah we can move on and
start doing things that we want to do
yeah and we never went without
i mean we had everything we need we had
a lot of family time we play board games
maybe less vacations or more
go visit family for vacations and so we
never went without
many people say you have can't take your
money with you
right we can't take our money with us
but we can leave our kids with
morals and values and um lessons to pay
off
and work ethic yeah and other things so
well done you guys
so proud of you thank you very neat very
neat okay now you're leading financial
peace classes you paid off your house
you're not even 40.
people ask how did you do that what are
the main ways that you tell somebody to
get out of debt
have an accountability partner for sure
we we don't keep anything back if i went
to mcdonald's
and we already spent over our budget i
have to tell them
if i wanted to buy that toy and i'd have
to come to her and say hey
is this a good idea and she said always
say no no definitely not
even though i really
but hey you went through the period of
saying no you know what you get to say
now
yes yes yeah yeah yeah you said yes to
your future i'm very proud of you too
thank you like no one else later you get
to live and give like no one else that's
right
absolutely amazing all right you brought
the kiddos what are their names and ages
uh grace is 10 and logan is seven
very good they're also big supporters we
we had a thermometer that we all crossed
off the next line
um every time we paid a little more off
yeah they've been they've been great
all right there we go so they've learned
it oh they have they know that their
family tree has changed
yes yeah you guys are so impressive
wonderful wonderful people
all right it's luke and sarah grace and
logan from columbus ohio ninety
thousand dollars paid off in two and a
half years
house and everything we're looking at
weird people
we got a copy of chris hogan's book for
you everyday millionaires without a
doubt that's the next chapter in your
story
so count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
all right guys you ready three two one
[Applause]
logan meant that logan meant that yeah
he's there he's made some sacrifices he
wanted everybody to hear that that's
fantastic
wow great points they made talking about
making sacrifices talking about
accountability people
being committed to the goal and being
driven uh wanting it bad enough that
you're willing to sacrifice for right
now and that that's all part of it dave
you know it i don't know what the
numbers are because i don't know that we
necessarily track it
um but it would be interesting if we
could go back and look over all the
years and
we have about 50 million dollars worth
of debt free screams a year on the air
on the air but how many of them that
have paid off their home
went from going to the class or
financial peace university or or reading
total money makeover to becoming a
leader yeah they're becoming
there's something about when you go from
baby step two and you're out of debt
and then you're gonna go on with four
five and six you're gonna knock the
house out the people
take that next step they go over and
they become a coordinator and i think
it's
a way to stay plugged in i i think so
but it's also
when you have something that impacts and
changes your life you can't help but
want to tell others
and be able to guide them and so you
know if you're out there and you're
wanting to get plugged in you've got
opportunities
i'm telling you i don't care where you
are in the plan if you're attacking debt
or maybe you're on baby step one and you
think i could help other people with
this yeah we can
we you can help people yeah just check
out ramsey plus and talk to that team
about being a coordinator for financial
peace university
and the people going through ramsey plus
some a lot of the coordinators are
virtual now
yeah because a lot of the classes are
virtual yeah and uh not all of them but
there's you know there's a
percentage that are and so um and i
guess
probably will be forever not because of
covid but just because that's the way
things are now that's right but hear me
again you do not have to be debt free to
be a coordinator
you can start helping people today nor
do you have to be perfect
because that would also rule me out let
me i'm not
he's gone who me me oh yeah
you two we go we go we go we go
we is gone
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
thank you for joining us on the ramsey
show the phone number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five colby's in sacramento
hi colby how are you i'm doing good how
are you doing mr angie
better than i deserve how can chris and
i help
awesome uh i have a good question
currently i'm in my third year
of college uh graduating for uh so we've
got about a year and a half left and
currently
right now i'm on baby step one i've
already saved my thousand dollars for my
starter
emergency fund and currently throughout
life i've worked hard at
many jobs and have saved up to about
thirty seven thousand dollars that are
all
in um stocks and uh currently have a 15
000
car loan and was just curious for baby
step two
it says pay off all debt um but right
now all of my stocks are making more
than my monthly
payment i was just curious on
what i should do and uh how do i
set up myself for success in the future
kobe i want you to brace yourself buddy
because
you said a key phrase how do you set
yourself up for the future
which means you're gonna have to let go
of some things you've previously learned
and some things you previously thought
because what we're about to tell you is
gonna be a paradigm shift it's going to
be counter to anything you've heard
and it's going to feel weird and your
brain is going to try to resist it
because it sounds so weird tell him dave
[Laughter]
well when chris and the team here did a
study on millionaires
we studied ten thousand of them not a
single one
of the ten thousand millionaires that we
studied said
i kept debt on my car and used that
payment
to put into single stocks and that
caused me to be wealthy
not a single one used leveraged car
loans to invest in stocks to become
wealthy not
one of the ten thousand which tells me
that your plan
sucks
that's what the data tells me okay
and so you've gotten lucky so far so far
the stocks have gone up
but they don't always go up and you're
carrying this extra debt how are you
paying for school
i'm blessed my parents are putting me
through school
great okay the good news is you've got a
great financial mind and you have the
ability to look at numbers
and that's gonna that's gonna bode well
for you if it doesn't
lead you into taking risks that you
don't even realize you're taking
yeah so if i woke up in your shoes this
morning what would i
do if i was your age knowing what i know
at 60 years old
with a net worth of hundreds of millions
of dollars what i would tell you to do
is what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes
if you were my son or
dad gum my grandson or whatever i would
tell you
to pay off the car today move your
single stocks into mutual funds
and be the tortoise yes don't be the
hare yep
there it is and and and i'm gonna tell
you
it's crazy colby but if i could go back
in time i'd grab me by my hair
[Laughter]
ramsay don't go there
back in the day but literally in that
mindset of getting away from a car
payment
of staying away from this cryptocurrency
phase
uh because another phase is coming and
it's a get-rich-quick scheme and uh
dave taught me something 15 years ago
don't get
rich build wealth there's a difference
in the mindset there's a difference in
the approach
and i'm gonna tell you it feels better
yeah you know there's no shortcut to any
places worth going
and very few people who get wealth
quickly keep it
it's very unusual uh so somebody hits
the lotto
the bankruptcy rate of people hit the
lotto is four-fold the national average
yeah um people who inherit money with no
effort and have been taught no character
or work ethic
promptly lose it and uh that doesn't
mean that everyone does that they don't
but i mean you can teach your kids and
they can the blessing the inheritance
can be a blessing
because they've got the character but
anytime there's quick rich
that it's uh the best way to get rich
quick is don't
get rich quick and so um that's where
all of this this where all these
these sayings come from true principles
and so that's what we tell you to do of
course you're you're a grown person
you're going to go do what you're going
to do
but ask yourself what the 30 year old
version of you
is going to think about the 20-something
version of you when you look back
did you have a fro when i was baby dave
when you're a baby i had a
can you think about this listen i had a
twa what's that it was a teeny weeny
afro
oh it was little it was little mama
hogan did it to me i wasn't old enough
i mean like like when you were a
teenager no i didn't think was your hair
no no it was it was it was a little i
just had a little bit because you're
always wearing a football helmet well
yeah well you don't want you don't mess
it you mash it down yeah i kept it low
okay
but story behind the first shaving of
the head
we said if we made it to the national
championship game in college we were all
going to shave our heads
and i'll be doggone if we didn't make it
and so that was the first time a razor
touched my head
and i never never went back never went
back i'm like this is a little bit and
then it wasn't optional i like
this yeah that's just you it is it is it
just
can't i can't imagine that head with a
fro on it that just would be more than i
mean like the full size
no i can't you know the big ones yeah
you know like in 1970s
you remember i mean that would be that
would be that's a picture i need
no i'll i'll find one on thursdays on
whatever it is twitter or
instagram i will reach out to mama hogan
and i will get that posted on instagram
follow me at chrishogan360 you are going
to see a small afro soon
yeah there you go there it is small one
small all right little
low yeah all right jake jake's in tacoma
washington hey jake what's up in your
world
hey good afternoon gentlemen first of
all and as a fellow bald man i i have to
say that
you guys have uh have great hair care
styles
jake you are the caller of the day you
are the caller whatever you want and
you can have it yep
hey so i got a question for you guys i
uh the company that i work for i'm in
baby step four
i i was super happy to be through baby
step three when
when when covet hit for sure but anyways
i'm on baby step four
and the question that i have is my
company has a rock 401k option that
matches 25 cents per dollar with no max
wow all 15 of my contribution go through
my yes
yes okay i'm not sure if any of that
needed to be split up into the ira
no you got a 25 rate of return if your
mutual funds completely bomb
perfect okay that's awesome yeah that's
killer yeah
definitely won't do that are they
matching you in company stock
uh no it is uh they go into the
traditional of course
yes yeah and then yeah right after after
i think i think it's after five years
you're completely invested but
i've been there for more than five so uh
100 percent uh matched every
well not 100 100 of their portion of the
contribution
is uh is just in the regular mutual
funds
jake that's a super cool benefit the
someone in leadership you ought to tell
them thank you give him a hug it's
highly unusual it is
but he brought up something dave even
with the roth 401k
the employer match version of that uh
it you do have to pay taxes on that okay
that's going in pre-taxed
uh but your money that's going in the
roth side of that in the roth 401k is
after tax uh but what is growing
tax-free and it is growing tax-free so
uh but that's a great opportunity uh for
him but traditionally this is a
teachable moment for all you listeners
out there
we don't factor in the employer match
don't care what they're doing
how much we call it icing on the cake
you want to flex the muscle of you
investing 15 of your income which he is
yeah but uh then then
and then we'll certainly take the match
your first priority is get all the match
you can get
your second priority is make sure you're
in a roth he's got the benefit of being
in both he's in both
and your third priority would be then to
do traditional something if you can't if
you can't fill it up
can't fill up your 15 in match and in
roth in his case he's got all of the
above so
very good now later on when you're in
baby step 7
you can once a year if you're vested
roll that money
out of the traditional over end of the
roth and pay your taxes on it once a
year
which is what i do on my personal one
once a year i
roll out the at the end of the year
matter of fact i just did it in january
uh rolled out the uh the match portion
where i match myself since i own the
company but this is dumber than crap but
anyway i match myself and then so uh and
i'm in baby step seven obviously
right so i would roll that out and pay
taxes on that portion
convert immediately and let it all grow
roth from that point
smart so i don't have any traditional
left
i've rolled it all over over the years
and each year i do it again so that i
never have any
it's all roth it's good stuff
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books chris hogan
my co-host james childs is our producer
kelly daniel is our associate producer
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental
studios it's the ramsey show where debt
is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsey show chris hogan
ramsey is my co-host today open phones
and you can get in
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
colton starts off this hour in nashville
hi colton how are you
i'm good how are you guys great how can
we help
good hey so i'm kind of
uh just i mean this is a good stress to
have i guess
um to a degree so i have
um right now about 7 000
in credit card debt and then
6 000 in student loans and then we have
about
uh 25 000 in my
car and then we have
um we're about to close on our first
house and
we are gonna need to put down um around
21 000 to avoid
and we have currently sitting in our
checkings around 87 000
and so i guess my question is um
do i obviously i'm going to have the 21
000 coming out in about a month for the
house
um do i tackle all these debts um
right now because we have the money or
i guess just kind of um get in the house
get that settled and then
what are those debts total um
so debt total um
were about 38 000 with the car student
loans my credit card debt
okay all right well we teach folks not
to buy a home until you're debt-free and
have your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses in place but it
sounds like we can do all three things
with eighty thousand dollars
yep yeah yeah so write a check and be
debt-free today a series of checks
put 21 000 aside for your
down payment and set the rest of it
aside as your
three to six months of expenses for your
emergency fund yep
okay colton if you if you do all of
those
if you do all of that after the 87
000 you would still have 21 000 left
as part of your three to six month
emergency fund
yeah and i and i think that that just
stresses me out because in my mind i
hate being under a certain amount in our
account
then you should sell your car what's up
then you should sell your car
i should sell my car yeah your car is
causing you stress
or you shouldn't buy this house it's
causing you stress
because when you start buying a bunch of
crap that you don't pay for
and you don't admit it yeah
then that and you act like you don't
have stress because the money's laying
over there in your account
that's that's falsehood that that's a
that's a foe
that's a faux piece it's not real peace
yeah and i think for our income level
i think that we're okay i think the
biggest thing is
about 130 um thousand per year yeah
great how old are you guys
um so i just barely turned 28 and then
my wife is 24. well you've done a good
job saving you've done a sucky job
with debt yep and you haven't done a
good job organizing all of this and you
just kind of go buy stuff whenever you
want to
that's right and you can clean all this
up in one fell swoop
because you've been savings good yep and
here's what will happen when
you get out of debt you don't have any
money i mean you got a 20 000 bucks or
so in your emergency fund you don't have
any debt except your whole new home
and be sure to put that on a 15-year
fixed by the way
not a 30. uh then what you're probably
going to do because you're a natural
saver you're probably going to put some
more in that emergency fund
before you start investing because that
21 000 is not enough for you
to feel comfortable that's not really uh
that's
maybe three months of expenses but it's
not six months and you probably want six
months since you're a saver
by nature yep but you're gonna have to
stop the stupid with the debt which
means
as you write these checks you guys are
looking at each other saying we're not
doing anything else
like prime example dave i feel this in
my bones i do it's not the cold weather
either it's wisdom
because you buy a new house and guess
what you think you got to buy new
furniture
yeah oh you got to get furniture because
you got the new house you need a new
couch the old couch can't come to the
new house
yes it can too because it's a couch okay
slow down they do what they're told slow
down
you're trying to do everything at this
light speed and i'm telling you it
increases debt back into your life move
with the furniture that you have
sit down make a plan that you're going
to save up and you're going to pay cash
yeah for furnishing the home yeah yeah
and if there's some rooms that are
unfurnished guess what
it's fine throw a box in there go sit
down on it it'll be fine
but i'm telling you this from wisdom
because i've done that stupid where you
feel this
com being compelled to do things before
you have the money and which
ends you it back in debt so colton take
a deep breath buddy
write checks clean this up and move
forward with your financial future on a
whole nother level
you guys need to get plugged into ramsey
plus the problem is you
you've not had a plan you guys have just
kind of been doing yeah that's that's
good
that's good you know i was just sitting
here thinking in the 60s
it was 1960s it was very difficult to
borrow to buy furniture
it was unusual and so my mom and dad
moved into
a 1 000 square foot three bedroom
one and a half bath ranch house with a
full basement in it
and um i remember most of my life
my younger light years anyway up until
maybe
i don't know 12 years old
our living room didn't have any
furniture in it
had this wonderful green shag carpet
that you had to rake
remember the rake you're right shade
carpet no dude you have to rake it it
had like a grain to it
and when you got finished vacuuming it
you had to rake it it like was like
cutting grass and so
but there was no furniture in there
until uh because we had the money to buy
furniture and you couldn't buy it they
wouldn't
i mean at least regular people i mean
rich people i guess could but i guess
regular people couldn't borrow money
because there was no rooms there they
went i mean it was just
there was you know no nothing down on
the couch or zero percent interest until
your taxes when does good stuff come
aboard that in the 80s
70s and big time in the 80s big time in
the 80s it starts showing up in the
mid to late 70s is the first time 90
days same as cash
particularly uh big in the 80s and uh
moved on from there but i mean it's just
so my point is that you're correct that
it's okay to save up and pay cash for
furniture it sure
is even if it's a few years which in his
case is not going to be he makes plenty
of money buying that gum couch but i had
a friend of mine he went to goodwill
got some furniture for a room and he
said when we get the money
one piece will leave at a time and i
never thought this guy would be that
kind of person but he put his pride
aside
and he goes we're not going to let this
rush us he could we've done stupid
before
and we bought a six thousand dollar
leather couch
for 600 bucks at a garage sale on the
rich people into town
yep that's what we did it was a great
leather couch i wish i had that leather
couch it was awesome
and it's probably still okay because
that leather lasts forever oh yeah it
was real cow
but yeah it was like a real cow and um
comfortable too but it was real
expensive
yeah rich people stuff and we bought it
for 600 bucks because they just changed
the color out you know mama's
redecorating oh yeah whatever over there
on that inaudible
yeah man it's amazing what happens if we
can change our thinking they probably
wish they had that count
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
better
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host
today our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free you get free
samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best possible
deal all right today's question comes
from rebecca and washington
she says i'm on step two of my baby
steps
a year ago i started a new job and was
given stock in my company
when i started our stock was around
thirty three dollars a share
my stocks have now vested and a quarter
of them are being released to me
shares are now sitting at 127 dollars
per share
is it wise to sell my shares to pay off
debt
or since our stock prices continue to
rise
should i leave my shares invested
oh rebecca listen to me
i want you to sell what you're able to
sell
be aware of the taxes reach out to a tax
elp
talk to a smart investor pro but get
this sold and apply it toward debt
as soon as possible absolutely
let's pretend because we don't know
numbers but let's pretend there's
twenty thousand dollars worth of stock
and there's twenty thousand dollars on a
credit card
okay so there's a way you can analyze
this rebecca in the future
and others have you and it's helped me
over the years to do this
i read it in the harvard investment
newsletter about
probably 25 years ago it's called a sunk
cost analysis and all that means is you
reverse
engineer it and you say what if i didn't
own this stock
and i didn't have this twenty thousand
dollars worth of credit card debt
if i had the opportunity would i borrow
twenty thousand dollars on my credit
card
to buy this stock at 127
it's the same exact math no it is the
reverse engineering though gives you
pause
yeah and makes your stomach leap into
your throat and go
i would not do that well if you don't do
that by holding on to the stock and not
paying off the twenty thousand dollar
twenty thousand stock and not selling it
at a hundred twenty seven dollars a
share to pay off a twenty thousand
credit card bill mathematically it's
exactly the same thing
wow when you reverse engineer it though
it grabs you by the heart
oh and you see it clearly and you quit
doing the math stuff
yeah and it's kind of like let's say you
could do that with anything i mean don't
have to be an investment
you can say i've got a 20 000 boat
sitting in my driveway
that i have not had in the lake in four
years
now if i had twenty thousand dollars
piled up in the middle of the kitchen
table
would i go buy a boat if i didn't own
one
and most people if you haven't had the
thing in the lake in four years would
say no
no which means it's time to sell the
boat
you would rather have the cash than the
boat right and when you
when you pretend like you're doing it in
reverse rather than the way you're
sitting on
right then it makes you go why am i
doing this yeah
and it really has helped me not do or
undo
a lot of things a lot of stuff that i
that i wouldn't ever go proactively do
another one of those that comes up often
is hey we want to move out of our
current
house and make it a rental
and go buy another house and have debt
on both of them
do should i do that well let's pretend
you were already over in house b
would you go buy that old house with
that much debt on it
as a rental and most the time people go
no well you're just becoming a landlord
by default
that's right not by intention and so
when you reverse this stuff sometimes it
grabs you around the throat and makes
you go
that's stupid yep i'm not doing that it
helps me a lot
no it does that's a really good way of
looking at it open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
derek is with us in minneapolis hi derek
how are you
hi thanks for doing thanks for taking my
question sure how can we help
well a couple things um when i was in
college i
had a ton of credit card debt and i said
i'd never do that again and kind of
worked my way out of it was pretty bad
and i was pre dave ramsey uh before i
knew about you
and my wife um she had a ton of credit
card debt and we worked really hard for
a year or two to get it paid off
recently i just bought a car from a guy
he asked me why i paid
cash for the card i could afford a
better car than that
and i said because i hate that so you
left your book and my car were the best
guess ever
so the question is twice now we've paid
off my wife's credit card we kind of
have things separated now
and now she wants to go back again to us
paying them off
because i'm kind of pushing the dave
handsy bottom how do i get her to be
motivated and not go the army back and
run a credit card debt again
why are your finances separated
well right away we're together we paying
off for credit cards is about
16 dollars how long you've been married
14 years
yeah so why are your finances separated
then this is this is this is why that
was the only like i lived my life to
death because the only battle we have is
that after we paid them off i thought we
were done with some
she told me she cut him up i actually
watched her cut him up
the next year when we got her tax
returns back and that's kind of we paid
our last thousand dollars on him with
her tax returns the next year
she said let's use the tax return to pay
off the credit cards there so we don't
have any credit cards
to have to worry about that to live nine
thousand dollars okay so you didn't
separate your accounts you never had
them together
no we had them together oh that's
impossible it's impossible that you had
them together because it's impossible
she has credit card debt
you don't know about if your finances
are together
right um my mom and dad were kind of
helping her on the side
doesn't matter oh so they're they're
paying the credit card bill so she can
hide it from you
pretty much yeah yeah so we separated
them for the next 14 years
and uh she asked me you know how much
money do you have so like that's the
kind of show when i see
she noticed i've saved up a ton of
wealth kind of
using your system by myself and now she
wants to get back on and do this
together
it's not it's not my system if you're
not doing it together yeah
okay and derek i'm going to tell you
this trying to do money stuff when you
guys got
you guys have a marriage issue there's
uh
you trust me we don't hardly ever fight
no no i'm not saying you you listen to
me some of the nastiest
fights are non-verbal and so what i'm
saying
is is you guys need to go sit down with
a marriage therapist a marriage
counselor and find out what this is
that's standing in the way of you all
connecting
because this money stuff has got to be
done together as a team
and it's putting the cards on the table
and being up front and reel
so you guys can make some decisions
about how you're going to move forward
your
your probability of continuing to build
wealth at the speed you should build
wealth
is very low until you guys get on the
exact same page
and you're making you're doing a monthly
budget together
that both of you know where every dollar
is going
before it goes and you're both in
agreement on the basic tenants of how
you're going to handle money in
emergency fund you're going to be debt
free we're not using credit cards
anymore
but you're sent her off over there by
herself and then you're shocked
that she runs up a credit card bill
that's not right
well she she makes a ton of money i
don't
care i'm asking yeah i know so i could
literally i can pay off all the credit
card bill
i don't care okay
you guys need to combine your freaking
lives
you're not going to fix this otherwise
you're right you got a roommate dude
are y'all are y'all splitting who uses
the mayonnaise
who uses the mustard i mean who gets to
drink
which which beer in the refrigerator
yeah oh my gosh
yeah you know y'all need to be on the
same
page it's a big deal man it's a big deal
and you do you do not grasp what you're
missing out on that
and then you're turning around and
acting like somehow she's deficit right
because she's running you know you said
go run your own finances
and then you're shocked that she did
of course she did yeah and of course she
did whatever the flip she wanted to do
so i don't think this is her fault dude
i think it's yours yeah no and
again you guys it's pronoun problems you
keep saying i and she
has got to be we what are we doing
moving forward i think the first step
you guys need to take
is to get with a marriage counselor to
sit down and get real about your
situation
and what you want from the future it's
imperative or you're going to keep going
in circles my friend
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the debt-free stage in
the lobby of
ramsey solutions joey and maylene are
with us hey guys how are you
good how are you great where do you guys
live we're um
southern south suburbs of chicago
austria welcome to nashville good to
have you down here in the middle of a
snowstorm yeah yeah
wow just like chicago or something huh
guess we brought it with us who would've
oh it's
your fault no we were wondering whose
fault he was why would you do that to us
how much how much debt have you guys
paid off we did 54
00 85 awesome how long did this take
um one year to the date 12 months
love it and your range of income during
that time it was
56 000 to 100 000. nice jump
whoa how did you how did you double your
income we just
we were very intentional it turns out
when you run a business with no debt you
can give yourself a
pay increase oh okay so you just said
i'm bringing more home
yes pretty much and worked all the time
yeah it did work a lot yeah what kind of
business have you got
um i have a pet salon and then a another
side hustle but um yeah i have a pet
salon
and that's where you made the money
that's where i made the money yeah okay
very cool
lots of pet care huh what do you do
i'm a union electrician in chicago local
134
good good for you guys well done
very well done what kind of debt was the
54 000
pretty much everything you say not to do
family loan
consolidation loan credit card from the
consolidation that we didn't close and
uh some
student loans and uh businesses
i had uh in the business i had taxes i
had um
and i say i because at the time i did
not involve him i was just doing it on
my
own and not really talking about it so
um it was a quick loan it was
that my mom did for me it was just
everything that you
talk about so you guys were normal we
were so super normal completely normal
so what happened because you did a
complete 180 this is amazing
um it started back i was working on
myself and um
seeing a just a counselor and i realized
that we were
like making all this money and we were
just living paycheck to paycheck and it
made no sense to us so
i just brought it up to him and um he
was fighting it for a little bit
and then i showed him i spelled out like
all our debts
not including the business but all the
debts and um
he saw the numbers and then he still
didn't want to do it
yeah they said we were too broke yeah
our
church um we go to parkview
and our church actually was having it at
a discount
the financial piece and so um i told
them i was like hey
i know we've been back and forth about
this but like they're discounting it and
it starts on tuesday like let's just do
this
and he goes we do not have any we don't
have the money to do that and
well that's why we need to do it so um
we signed the next morning for our
daughter's birthday he
signed us up and we started our journey
wow so harlow's church
yeah uh-huh oh he's a good friend yeah
good man
yeah joy his son-in-law used to work
here for a long time yeah
cool joey as you look back on it what
was the thing standing in your way
um i think just believing in it she
pushed me over that edge and you know
got us going when
i started downloading this stuff it
turns out i had the every dollar
app on my phone for like two years and
never opened it
and uh you know her pushing us forward
and
really getting it in my face showed me
it's totally doable
so how far were you into the class joey
before you went ding ding
uh game on that first class oh the first
one yeah i was
wow easily persuaded wow you know i saw
it i'm like
this all makes sense let's let's go all
in so you didn't hear
that yeah because i i'm like you in the
sense i go into stuff a lot of times
with my shields all up i'm like
i'm a scam alert scam alert scam alert
is this guy is this guy is this guy what
is this guy
and um then when it takes me a little
while to believe
on something and um because i have the
gift of cynicism
but uh but once i do then i'm all i'm
i'm all in and that sounds like what you
did yeah mm-hmm
yeah we're all in yeah that's what a lot
of people do and that's okay
way to go man way to go you guys yeah i
love that you guys it sounds like you're
united
it does yeah in a big way and i i give
all the glory to god because
he truly guided us our path to this la
where we are now and
strengthen our marriage our marriage is
in a whole new
place and it's it's the best thing yeah
that's awesome
yes so proud of you guys thank you very
well done
so when someone hears you paid off 54
000
in one year you completely combined your
finances
yes and we're making more money than
we've ever made in our lives
and they say how do you do that what do
you tell them the key
is um for me the key really is just
communication that's one of the things
that when we got married i always told
them
i sometimes am over communicative but
now
that we've gone through this it's really
just communicating about every part of
our your life when you're in marriage
and um
not being afraid to talk and just
lay it out there and not judge each
other and just know that we're each
you know we all have our faults so just
be open with each other
and it's a beautiful it just makes the
world a difference yeah teamwork
and then budgeting yeah like a budget is
so much
so freeing yeah that's and it seems like
it's going to be the opposite when you
start
yeah i was yeah i think that was my
biggest thing because if budget's going
to be a straight jacket yeah when we
started
i had a plan for her 30th birthday
and i was going to take her to nashville
and i was like all right we can do this
but let me still put this money aside
but you can't know why
i was like no we can't do that it's not
just
cash flow it's fine just yeah trust me
and i fought him all the way up until
um the shutdown happened and we were
stuck at home we got back
to work and i'll tell you what i was
like let's just let's just breathe and
go take a break and um
we came here and it truly just kind of
because during the shutdown because we
were budgeting we were able to get
through it without taking any more debt
we were able to just pay off
um and still pay off our debt in the
time frame we wanted to
so it was just like a relaunch to both
of us and we sat down and revisited
where we were at
and that just like skyrocketed us right
to the end
we were our goal was to be done by the
31st
of last year and bring in the new year
that way
and it was probably the end of august
i was looking at the bank statements and
i was like we have this much left
and we have this much in the bank like
we can just take it all out
everything is paid for and we were able
to pay it off
on our daughter's seventh or sixth
birthday which was to the date when we
started
i love it she got to hit the button so
oh that's fun
yes it was awesome the button is her
family tree being changed
yeah wow very neat yeah well
congratulations
you guys i'm appreciative of pastor
harlow and parkview and the guys
teaching the class makes it available to
you guys absolutely
well done very very well done good stuff
who are your biggest cheerleaders you
know i would have to say um
for the most part everybody closest to
us were very like on board they weren't
quite understanding why we were doing
things we did but um
his mother was really in shock she was
so proud like happy for us
but she was like you guys are working
all the time and
um we were meeting babysitters like all
the time
so just to uh really all of our friends
and
i'd say even if they didn't understand
they stuck beside you they stuck beside
us yeah
that's family and i'd say anybody who
said we couldn't do it
yeah that was fuel kept us going
you're that guy yeah i like it all right
one thing i was really excited about
with this journey is
it also got my parents on board because
we both grew up with
you know our parents didn't necessarily
know how to manage money together or
just
in general and all of them or my parents
ended up doing the journey
and they also became debt-free in the
same time as uh
let's get the kids in what are their
what are their names and ages emma
is six and layla is two and we got a
copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires that's the next
chapter in your story emma
and leela layla layla i'm sorry and
meline and joey from chicago
54 000 paid off in 12 months count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three two
[Applause]
yeah fantastic this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we want to
transform so many lives
that disruption spreads like wildfire
across our country
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan
instead of assuming that it's the only
way to get an education imagine a world
where the majority of people pay cash
for their cars
imagine a world where credit cards are
the cigarette of the financial world
imagine being part of causing that level
of disruption
with the work that you do every day
at ramsey solutions that's why we have a
thousand people at our company working
together to create
digital products and services to help
people transform their lives
with the goal of disrupting the toxic
culture in america whether it's
parenting
marriage mental health with dr john
money careers with ken coleman
we want to disrupt it if you want to
join us on that crusade we're on the
hunt
right now for software engineers with
expertise
in ruby on rails java c-sharp run-in
technologies
if you're a ux designer seo and content
marketing specialist
we'd love to talk with you as a matter
of fact we're going to hire about 250
people next year
or this year and a bunch of those hires
are on our website at daveramsey.com
click
the dave's hiring tab on the right-hand
side
of the home page to see all of our
opportunities
wow lots of stuff going on here chris it
really is
and you know you talk about being on a
mission to to disrupt
the culture that's exactly what we're
about and for a lot of people
2020 was a year of reflection for you
where you looked around and you realized
that maybe you weren't working at the
kind of place you wanted to be
well this is the time to make that
change we talk about controlling the
controllables
and so you've got a great opportunity to
join a team that's on a mission
uh and so go over check it out if you're
interested go ahead and apply
uh don't wait any longer because i'm
going to tell you we're voted as the
best place to work because that's
exactly what we are
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five jason is in washington d.c
hi jason welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you it's an honor to speak with
both of you you too how can we help
i lost my dad about six weeks ago no
what happened uh it was a brain
infection
it was rather sudden he had a tumor
uh and then it went to infection it was
it wasn't expected of course
and uh um he was gone within a few
months wow i'm sorry
thank you uh we're still in a bit of
shock of course
i'm helping my mom with next steps i
wanted to ask how to best
help her invest we have a smart investor
pro meeting in a couple weeks
um she the only said is a house it's
nearly paid off
uh but he did leave my mom 350
a thousand in insurance in life
insurance i did those
claims um just not quite sure uh
obviously we'll work with the smart
investor pro but let's see what your
thoughts were
okay so is that all the money she has
she's about ten thousand liquid and a
checking account she's
she gets a fixed income she's going to
get my dad's check
uh it's a total she'll have about 3 200
a month and fixed income every month she
can
afford that without protecting
this insurance money we're going to have
to sell the house
to do a downsize her finish only on the
sixth income
how old is she 66.
okay all right so the plan is to move
down into a house that she can afford
and pay cash for it i take it
correct um she the current house is
about 300 000
um there's about seventy thousand left
on the mortgage and you can get her a
house to about 200
okay and she's okay with this idea
she loves it she's the big house she's
ready to look down
perfect okay well that's and that's
still going to leave the 350 clear right
mm-hmm
correct yeah so that you're we're just
going to invest that money and let that
add to her monthly income
um she should be able to invest it with
a smart vester pro and
those mutual funds should create a
monthly income for her
to add to what she's already got it's a
fairly clean
process um i'm glad she's got you there
walking with her
yes yeah and she's you know jason your
mom is young
um at 66 so you know glad that you're
going to invest it have a long-term kind
of mindset
uh for her and moving forward um
and yeah if you can live off of the
income that she has
plus the income that those mutual funds
create with no house payment that's what
she probably can do it sounds like
yeah um then you know you're going to
let that money sit there and it may even
grow
you may not even pull all of the income
off of it you don't have to
there's not a rule that says you have to
but but also would want her to be taking
good care of
with the in terms of the margin in her
monthly budget i don't want her on
beans and rice right there's no reason
no reason for her to have to be here
so i mean she should have an income of
with all of it combined
north of six or seven thousand dollars a
month and i think she can make it on
that with no housing no house payment
absolutely
yeah but just let people know out there
you know if you're ever bumping into a
situation where
it's in your family or you bump into
friends that have lost a loved one
and if insurance money is coming in we
typically advise that you
park that money for three to six months
just set it over in a money market
account
uh and and get yourself together kind of
get your heart
in the right place get a game plan get a
structure
because what you don't want to do is
ever fritter away
or or misuse that money it's very
important that you become extremely
intentional
and sometimes parking it there for three
to six months will let you get yourself
together so you can make the right
decisions
absolutely in this case there's no
downside to going forward with what
that's right that's right that's a way
of parking it because we're not
using it that's the point it's just
going to be sitting there invested
so um oh well hey man
thank you for the call i'm sorry what a
horrible thing you guys have gone
through
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money esteban is with us in
fayetteville arkansas hi esteban how are
you
hey that um sorry uh good thanks for
asking i just want to say it's a
say thank you for uh taking uh my call
i've been watching you guys for
a couple years now and so it's just an
honor to be able to speak with you guys
you too how can we help awesome so um
i'm 19 years old i recently just got
married to my wife um she's 18. we live
in fayetteville arkansas
um and now we recently just found out
that she's pregnant
and so we're going to be expecting in
november yay
yeah pretty exciting um we have about a
little over five thousand dollars saved
up right now
um our goal for doing the baby steps was
saving our three to six months worth of
expense um
saving that three to six months um but
now we're expecting and so i was just
wondering
what's kind of the is there anything
that should shift or
change or what should we prioritize
right now on doing
yeah well the only thing we teach you to
do while you have a baby on the way is
not do the baby steps you just push
pause
in the middle of them wherever you are
and pile up as big a pile of cash as you
can possibly pile up between now and the
time baby comes
there's no downside to that because
after baby comes and baby's okay mommy's
okay and come home from the hospital
we take that money take it back down to
the thousand dollars at that point baby
step one
pay off all debts and two three finish
the emergency fund
we work the baby steps with that money
so it's just a nine
month delay on getting started but
meanwhile you're palling up cash to get
a quick start
okay is there a certain number that we
should kind of aim for
no to have saved up as big as you can
save as much as you can possibly save
there's not you can't have too much in
your savings account
right yeah because that's the bond
you're gonna once
as they've said once the baby gets here
you're gonna start now taking that money
and you're going to start applying it to
the baby steps and it's going to
it's going to keep you right on pace my
friend
right now go ahead
oh i was just saying i haven't i have an
associate's degree i graduated
i'm from an early college high school
and so i applied to u of a
um to go in the summer um now do you
think we should probably
wait on going me finishing school i'm
fine with you going as long as you pay
cash for it yup
just don't go into debt yep yeah you're
that'd be awesome if you finished up
your school
now what a great life you've lined up
for yourself young man well done
very well done that puts us our the
ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host chris hogan
ramsey personality and author of the
book
every day millionaires is
my co-host today this is a millionaire
theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires not someone with an
opinion
someone who really has a million dollars
and asking them
how they got it where it came from how's
it invested
and uh so you can learn maybe you want
to be one too
a millionaire is a million dollar net
worth that's right not a million dollar
income that's exactly right and let me
define that so you know what you do you
take all that you own
and subtract out anything that you have
debt on so i'm talking about bank
accounts 401ks 403bs iras
all of those things add it up subtract
out anything with that on it if the
n number is a million dollars or more
then congratulations
you're an everyday millionaire that's it
that's it what you own minus what you
owe your assets minus your liabilities
is your net worth and that is really
the most accurate measure of wealth
income is not wealth credit score
sure is crud is not wealth it just means
you've been playing kissy face with the
bank
and so the you know what is a real
millionaire where do they come from
what does real wealth look like in
america today
so if you have a net worth of a million
dollars or greater call us
we're going to talk to you and ask real
people not your broke brother-in-law
but real millionaires how they did it
and who they are
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five mike is our first one up mike what
is your net worth
1.48 million say it again
one point four eight million okay
million four eight
and uh break that down for me how is
that invested the
the categories yes i've got that about
640k
and a 401k and roth ira i've got 450k
in an esop employee stock ownership
program about 80k
and other mutual funds 280k is my house
and about 30k in cash
all right good for you mm-hmm very cool
and so how old are you i'm 44. oh young
guy
good for you so how much of the 1.48 did
you inherit
zero zero and what has been your income
range in your working lifetime from the
time you started working your worst year
to your best year so i started at 41k
and i'm about 112k now cool what do you
do for a living
i'm an engineer good friend so you did
get a degree
do you remember your gpa yeah i got a
master's degree my gpa was 3.8
3.8 all right and do you do any giving
as a household yes we consistently give
about 12 to 15
income that's fantastic and tell me this
what was your biggest money stupid
throughout your journey to becoming an
everyday millionaire
um i don't think we made any big
mistakes
i would say my biggest mistake was just
getting being slow about paying myself
first
hmm um you know i did some of the
standard you know some early minimal
consumer debt and credit cards but we
got rid of those pretty quick
okay once once i started investing
regularly and paying myself first to
making automatic that made a big
difference
yeah because just your 401k and your
esop has got you over a million dollars
yeah yep yeah way to go man
congratulations i'm proud of you
so what advice would you have for the 25
year old version of you sounds like get
started earlier right
yeah no get started really my my
supervisor encouraged me to contribute
to my retirement right away
and i took that to heart but i would say
invest in yourself pay yourself first
and make it automatic that that made a
huge difference
it does automatic discipline is easy
discipline
yeah and so you didn't use debt to
create wealth did you
no not at all okay all right so a couple
of myths
uh debunked right there right off the
bat so
mike thank you for the call well done
congratulations it's a millionaire theme
hour
we are talking to real millionaires the
phone number if you want to be one of
them on the air
is triple eight eight two five five two
two
five engineer is one of the top five
that hit your
research on millionaires it sure did we
had engineers we had accountants
and then school teachers teachers hit in
at number three which
blows people away but if you start to
think about it teachers love a plan
they follow a plan and they're
intentional and so
what that really boiled down to show is
that it has nothing to do with your
income date it's about having a plan
yeah it really is and so we want to hear
from you we don't care if you invented
something
if you want it in the lottery maybe you
had inheritance maybe you
inherited it either way we want to hear
from you because
this guy was not making 400k a year he's
making a max of 112. yeah
he's only 44. um
i mean he he did not inherit any money
and he did not borrow money to make
money nope and so all the mythology
that's out there you know this is
people inherited their wealth their
crooks their famous entertainers
they have uh you know 4.6 gpas or
whatever they're geniuses
we don't find that to be true most of
the time occasionally one of them is but
yeah
bob is next bob's in fayetteville
arkansas hey bob what's your net worth
well hello my net worth is 1.15
and we actually just got over that
during the pandemic
okay great okay cool so break that down
for me what are the categories and how
much in each category
well um we have about 540 in mutual
funds
220 in real estate and 243 in cash
and then we got about eighty thousand
dollars in uh it's insured for that
and collectible musical instruments
sports cards and guns
cool good for you that's fun okay and
how old are you
we're 70. good for you all right and how
much of the
million 115 did you inherit
well about 15 years ago my parents who
were wonderful
christian parents but not much in
financial training
they gave us a thousand dollars and said
this is probably your inheritance and as
it turns out it was
okay all right and what has been your
range of income during your working
lifetime your best year
and your worst year of income
well when we first got married
we had one income as uh for two school
teachers
uh because we only had one job we made
six thousand four hundred dollars
for the year and then that increased as
school teachers go we were both music
teachers and um
so um the last year that we taught
we i made 41 and she made 38
uh that was the last year before we
retired now our
highest annual income is actually then
after retirement because our mutual
funds have done uh
pretty well and because we uh do a
little uh
part-timing stuff and draw our
retirement
all right and so your best year teaching
was combined
79 and what's been your other best year
well with everything all the retirement
plans were drawing at
social security and teacher retirement
and uh
all of that 160 is what we were taxed on
last year
oh wow wow excellent okay good for you
well done well congratulations sir
seriously
music teacher with music instruments
that are collectibles i bet that's an
interesting room i bet it is well done
bob well done
real millionaires on the millionaire
theme hour
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
it's a millionaire theme hour here on
the ramsey show as we talk to real
millionaires people with a net worth
of a million dollars or greater to learn
where they got it
who they are and so you can emulate them
you can copy them you can learn
best practices from them because we
want you to have abundance we want you
to live
and believe in proper principles that
will take
you to abundance i think you will notice
as i've done the millionaire theme hour
now for many years
that i've never talked to a single
person who said i became a millionaire
because the government gave me so much
money
my stimulus checked made me a
millionaire these are words i have never
heard
no and you know what else hadn't heard
dave credit card miles
made me a millionaire hadn't heard that
never heard it hadn't heard that one
bonus miles all those things
very seldom here uh i inherited it yes
very seldom yeah and um statistically
it's less than seven percent of you that
are millionaires
uh actually inherited your money most of
93
did not become millionaires according to
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america
airtight um
[Music]
airtight statistical analysis and
research uh
uh format that we used uh to wear
because we knew some of you with lefties
would go bananas
because you don't like people telling
you know like us telling people that
they
have responsibility for their own lives
well
and you know what you they'll be okay
the reality is is we are in control of
our destiny
and that's one of the stats that jumps
out by the way you can get all these
statistics
uh we've got the national study uh of
everyday millionaires available where
you can get just the stats you want the
white paper it's the white paper
you can read all that but one of the
shocking ones in there was 97
of the millionaires surveyed said that
they felt that they controlled their
destiny
versus 50 of general population and that
was regardless of
race yeah regardless of
uh ethnicity
uh region right uh it was a belief
yes mindset it was i you know i know
there's crap i have to climb over
i know i'm gonna run into morons along
the way um
and i know i'm gonna get some help along
the way from good people right
um and uh but i believe it's up to me
yeah
and it's it's this realization dave that
everybody we're all running this same
race
right in the race of legacy and we all
have different start points
some people do have some challenges that
they have to deal with others start off
a little bit ahead but we're all running
it in
and it's us against us and having that
mindset that that's the finish line that
i'm going for
it's possible it is possible 97 of the
millionaires said it was their own
destiny when we did
when we surveyed and asked the public
how much of their
how much do they think yeah the general
public was 62 percent was it 62 i said
55.
it's okay 62 but a drastic decrease
yeah and so in other words it's not the
only thing
right but it is a big thing to actually
believe that it's possible which is why
we do this show
because you and i have overcome baldism
in order to become wealthy we sure did
we had to come overcome baldism because
everybody has something they have to
overcome hey
some mountains are taller than others
that's not a real tall mountain
but it is a thing but you told me
there's never been a bald president
since television since television
dwight d eisenhower was the last one
other than gerald ford but he didn't get
elected
president that's right he was i you know
he became president on nixon's
resignation right
and he never got reelected he got beat
in the re-election
so there you go i'm telling you i'm
telling you but seriously we have the
ability
to be able to build wealth it's about
being intentional that's why we're doing
this hour so you can hear directly from
them
eric is in detroit eric what is your net
worth
about 1.85 million dave good for you and
give me the breakdown by category some
dollars per category okay about uh
550 in retirement and investments
150 in cash and about 1.2 million in
real estate which is
six rentals and a primary residence so
seven total
all paid for all people wow wow
big real estate guy okay how old are you
i just turned 52 yesterday awesome
you're like a poster child that's our
average age
of the millionaires and the ones we
studied by the way so good for you
so how much of the 1.5 did you inherit
about 50 000 okay were you already a
millionaire when you got it
i don't know exactly it's hard to say
because you know you know in detroit we
had that property crash and everything
so i probably wasn't but i don't think
that that actually made me want to eat
there
okay so you not you didn't take that 50
000 and parlay it into a million five
no i didn't think so in fact
in fact one part behalf of it's sitting
as an inherited ira
oh so you never ever touched it okay all
right and so the
uh uh what what has been the range of
your income over your working lifetime
your best year and your worst year
oh god uh well i was a
waiter looking for a job making 15 000 a
year and i probably made between you
know
150 and up before you know business
deductions and stuff with the rentals
got you so what is your career
i'm a lawyer okay good for you and
you were more of a real estate guy than
a lawyer i understand i understand
obviously you got your degree you went
to law school what was your gpa
well in undergrad my gpa was a 365.
um in environmental science and
photography i was really planning dave
they have to listen to you
you know i i i hear that you know the
creative writing degree and in law
school it was only about a two nine
because i don't like to read
okay all right and do you and in your
family do you all do any giving
yes what kind of giving do you do well
i'm very involved in the ferndale elks
foundation and the national organization
so i do a lot of work in giving there
and i do a lot of work with uh animal
shelters
gotcha good for you sure that's fun so
uh before you were a millionaire
how many brand new cars did you buy
uh let's see
i bought one and least one okay
i never released again after that okay
so what is the uh dumbest financial
thing you've ever done
well i mean you've always bought stupid
stuff at times in your life and then you
can't go and put it back but i think
the the biggest financially was that i
bought my first
house that i lived in uh in 98 and i
didn't have enough money
to to remember that oh you're gonna need
a roof or have money for a furnace
or anything like that i didn't have the
reserves i had and i even paid pmi
so that was that was all a good learning
experience luckily you know i didn't
lose it it didn't go it didn't go south
i got out of it eventually and uh and
then when i went to the next house i put
20
down i got a 15-year mortgage like you
talked about
and i think i paid it off in about 10
and a half years cool
wow cool how many properties do you own
uh six rental houses and one primary
residence all like within
a mile or two of where i live okay good
good
and so you've enjoyed that whole process
obviously and by and paying cash for
them or getting them paid off very
quickly one of the two
yeah no i pretty much load them one
after another um
you look back and you go wow i could
have bought more and but then you also
then could have lost them
so uh you know i'm very happy with what
i have and i
you know you can always say oh i could
have done better but what are the
significant downsides
no you're right and so where did you get
this premise where did you learn about
money
the right way um my parents were my my
parents were both pretty depression
error mentality even though they weren't
of that era
okay and my dad was an engineer and
self-employed so i learned a lot of the
self-employeds
of uh you see the contractor in the
mercedes the one day and then in a
broken truck three years later because
it crashed
and my father was like that's how you
don't do it and uh so i looked at that
from the real estate perspective
yeah and my first house in detroit like
my own house was
lost 65 of its value during the crash
and the house down the street all of a
sudden was selling for thirty five
thousand dollars
wow and i was like well it's never gonna
be worth nothing
and so i i decided i'd buy it i thought
i knew someone looked at it for 131
and i was gonna buy a car i was gonna
buy a new camaro so i call the house the
camaro yeah
very well done very well different way
of thinking
good job brother well done proud of you
this is a millionaire theme hour here on
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a millionaire theme hour here on
the ramsey show chris hogan
author of the number one best-selling
book everyday millionaires
is my co-host as we talk to real
millionaires how did they get there who
are they lee is with us in south
carolina lee what is your net
worth how about 1.5
good for you now break that down for me
in terms of
category and dollars
category dollars almost all of it is in
literal dollars uh i don't count uh
on their ass my other assets bring it up
to about
0.5 up to about 5 million or up to about
another half a million
no another house point five so you have
a million and a half
you have a million and a half in cash
uh no uh about about one in cash
and the rest of it uh is in other assets
okay so that's it okay i'm cash i never
had cash in my life
and my greedy hands hung on to it when i
got it
from being 100 broke in debt
basically almost the bankruptcy when i
was 42 and we all have our sob
story i had three kids in private school
or in university i was struggling
lost the job but i was just broke
and and somehow
it all worked out it's a miracle and
being cash poor and insecure about
stock markets that oh it's all going to
be bad it's kind of this this this and
this
so i would have more if i wouldn't have
been so frightened of the stock market
anyway with my wife who was always over
caution
however we
got a job thank god got a job saved
every money
helped our kids to school taught them to
work they worked their way through
school
came out of school with no debt they
drove junkers the way we drove
junkers and they've all done the kids
have all done exceedingly well i'm not
bringing them on and growing complaining
at the fact
all three of them are millionaires plus
blood
wow some grandkids are well on their way
wow
how old are you
a minimal amount i mean minimal from my
wife's parents when they died
it was basically nothing
and uh no we worked and uh
what'd you do for a living well i
you know what i was a corporate pilot up
until i was
42 and in and out of jobs that companies
hadn't done that job
and uh i believe we're going to uh
our plane's being repossessed and back
into sometimes
the 70s and early 80s it was almost
impossible to find a corporate job
but finally at 42 i finally got hired by
an airline
and being 100 percent broke out 18 years
until i had was obligated to retire
at age 60 they since raised age 65.
so i scrambled like man we paid our
house
to help the kids with their death did
this did that
three kids got married they were on
their own and we
saved money and were exceedingly
frugal and finally in the last five
years with the airline i
finally had some decent income and we
squandered that away and they
were at age 60 in 2002
i've been retired since and uh
and oh nobody anything and during this
time we always paid tithes
and then with my kids my last kid left
the house
which was though 30 something years ago
we began paying 20 without failing every
penny that we had coming in wow plus
giving someone decide
so again not back bragging blowing
growing and complaining
i was thankful until now at this age
wife and i still have good health yeah
with enthusiasm
trying to play tennis every day or do
our thing i love it and
been to more countries than there are
states
lee i love you man well done that's a
beautiful story
it is all the way from 42 and just said
enough already
and uh in the career and saves
everything
sitting on a million dollars cash yeah
at 78. and not just him
but he's raised his kids three and a
half million of them are millionaires
there was a story in that yeah it was
very cool well talk about being
intentional
williams in oshkosh wisconsin hey
william what's your net worth
my net worth is uh 1.3 million sir good
for you give me a little breakdown on
that by category
um it's probably going to be the most
boring story
uh you hear today um there's about a
million dollars of uh just
mutual funds and ira and 401k and then
our house is paid for at 300 000.
that'll do it but about 1.3 million
that's that's what we hear a lot
actually very well done how old are you
okay okay i am 45.
okay and what was your best oh how much
of this did you inherit
um essentially none of it we'll just say
none of it yeah i've got a little bit
like a lot of people got a little bit
but that certainly was not
remotely tipping any scales whatsoever
gotcha and your worst share of income to
your best year of income what was the
range
my worst i my first job on a dairy farm
was 18 000
a year and then my best year of sales
was probably
plus 100 plus in that kind of ballpark
okay so you were in sales all right yep
i was in sales and dairy farm management
quite frankly
yeah and so did you get did you go to
college
i went for two years i did not graduate
from college
gotcha and do you remember your high
school gpa
uh 3.401 because you had to have a 3.4
to get in the national honor society
3.401
do you and your family do you do any
giving
um that's probably the best part of
having
the blessings that we've we've got
uh yeah we do giving and uh it's
all anonymous and it's all local
and uh it's the best part of having been
given the gift of good influences to put
us in this position
yeah talk about the influences who were
they how did that work
um i was raised by a single mom and we
were
incredibly poor um when we brought him i
did not have a bed
we did not have a tv a couch
refrigerator and so the one best thing
that my mom did was she sent me to work
um on some dairy farms when i was a
teenager and i learned that work ethic
that is incredibly hard work that is
work
and you work and you work and you get up
at four o'clock the next morning and you
work
and they they don't have snow days and
they don't have vacation that's right
that is correct sir yes that is correct
so
that's that's what that was the
influence without a doubt that's what
that's what changed the cycle in my for
me
um undoubtedly was was were those
those influencers and those people that
that were in my path
that i got to learn from to say so let's
reverse that what advice do you have
let's reverse that and make you the
influencer what advice do you have to
the 25 year old version of you
that's out there what should they be
doing to get to be you when they're 45
um they should have a very simple plan
and live on less than you make and also
realize that what society tells you
is wealth is a lie and that the people
that society
likes to paint the picture as wealthy or
rich generally are
not and and the guy in the store who's
maybe not wearing the coolest clothes
that drive the nicest car
has five million dollars of wealth we
just don't know it
and uh that that's that's that's what i
would tell myself or reinforce myself at
25 and
anybody else like do not yeah be
unassuming
that's exactly right and and i like that
dave don't get caught up in the world's
definition of wealth
because they're stupid no i mean really
no
you know everybody's talking about it
right everybody's complaining about it
right nobody's doing anything about it
and then you find the guy or the gal
that did something about it and that's
who they are they're driving a nice car
but it's not flashy nope and their
clothes are clean and pressed
but they're not flashy and that's how it
works
you know a friend of mine grew up on a
dairy farm she said she was grown before
she found out that labor day was not the
day you worked the hardest that's what
her dad told her
wow millionaire theme hour here on the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 34 4
i sought the lord and he answered me and
delivered me from
all my fears
my friend rush limbaugh who passed away
today rest in peace rush
said i don't think looking at things
through the prism of fear is going to
accomplish anything
agreed agreed
it's a millionaire theme hour here on
the ramsey show if you
have a 1 million net worth or greater
chris hogan ramsey personality i want to
talk to you and get the real
story folks it's that time of year again
yep
tax season and look we got lots of irons
on the fire i know it makes taxes
complicated i use a pro for my taxes
because i don't want to mess with it if
your taxes are not complicated
and you want to go file online by
getting some good tax software
text the keyword uh well the key here
keyword here is good by the way and you
want good
software and that's why my team is
introducing ramsey smart
tax it is our brand new tax filing
software and it's a great option if
you've got simple taxes
and all you do is text the word tax
to 33789 and we'll tell you more about
ramsey smart tax
very inexpensive very easy for those of
you that have a simple return we're not
gonna send you like
credit card offers and home equity loan
offers
and mortgage offers and all that stuff
we're simply gonna
help you get your taxes done text the
word tax to 33
789 that's 33789 text
tax all right adam is in richmond
virginia hi adam what is your net worth
it's a million with a few thousand over
top of that
cool and break that down for me by
category
so retirement is 460. the house is
k-75 to 400. we've got 60k on 529.
70k in cash and then i'll put 25k
and guns toys and tools okay
cool so how old are you i'm 47
and my wife is here she's she's a little
younger than that
okay cool i love it how much of this one
million dollars did you guys inherit
so uh my dad actually did pass a few
years ago and he left me some things
that were probably about
around 25k or so okay so
safe to say unless you parlay that 25k
into a bunch of money you're not a
millionaire because of
an inheritance not because of an
inheritance but because of appearance
for sure
yeah well the influence and the teaching
yes and the lifestyle
yes yeah so give me your range of income
through your working lifetime
best year and worst year yeah uh
total household uh we started out you
know 24 25 years ago
uh 30k and then last year was our best
year at 164.
okay cool what do you do for a living i
tell people i'm an engineer which is
what my degree is but then i moved over
to sales and
started doing that and training got you
and what's your wife do
she's a social worker gotcha and did you
guys both get degrees
we did yeah both got a bachelor's degree
all right and what was your gpa
adam so uh in community college because
i did the uh
knock it out in two years and then go go
to the four year college
yep i was a ran a 3-3 and then i tell
people i graduated from the four-year
college
virginia tech with a 3-0 but it was
actually a 2.945
i just rounded up okay you are an
engineer for sure uh
what was your wife's gpa he was a
three-five
okay and are you smarter than me yeah
there you go smart man
you all do any giving as a family we do
we do through church and we do through
others
gotcha and tell me this what was one of
the biggest money mistakes you guys made
in your journey
you know i think we look back at it
we've bought one new vehicle
and uh we've been married a little while
and we had this thing going called a
truck fund
so we were saving for about a year and a
half and we saved about 7 500 bucks
and it finally just couldn't wait any
longer so we went out and bought a
22 000 truck which i still have today
but that was probably the the biggest
thing that was the uh the one new car
that we financed
gotcha cool so talk about
you said what your parents didn't give
you was money but they did give you
um habits character something i mean
what do you attribute
uh what did you get from them that you
attribute to your ability to become a
millionaire at 47 years old
yeah definitely both work ethic my dad
was a construction for years
in construction for years i was
electrician until as he says he retired
to maintenance
uh my mother you know he was actually my
step father but he's my dad
and um my mother for years was raising
my sister and myself
and uh you know working two three jobs
minimum wage
uh refugees are going welfare but you
just see the work ethic there
and then a lot of the things you know um
that my dad taught me about
you know financial how to handle money
uh when i started listening to you i
just started checking the box and saying
oh
yeah yeah he told me those things he
wasn't lying
he knew what he was talking about
that's really neat and and to your
knowledge adam are you the first
millionaire in your family
um no actually uh he made it so he did
okay or they my parents made it okay
that's fantastic wow very cool very cool
well
i mean we always have parents ask okay
it's one thing to build wealth but then
how do you keep that from ruining your
children
and the quite to the contrary in your
case it not didn't ruin you
it made you in the sense of he taught
you the habits and the character
qualities
that allowed you to be able to pull this
off and that's what i wanted to get at
because i hear that all the time
that can also be passed as an
inheritance that's right that's true tim
and they did it much later in life too
i mean i paid my way through college my
wife you know got a lot of
scholarships and her parents helped her
but you know when i went to college
that's why i went
went to the community college route
because we just did we didn't have the
money
so again they they achieved that mark
well when you know after we were married
yeah very cool well done sir very very
proud of you very proud of you chris
hogan's book everyday
millionaires the white paper is
available at daveramsey.com for ten
dollars the book is there for
probably around twenty dollars and you
can pick it up on amazon as well but the
white paper if you for those of you that
are nerds i want to dig
through the details of the study that
was done
uh we did it in conjunction with a firm
out of a research firm out of new york
uh uh to have someone looking over our
shoulder to hold to the legitimacy of
the
findings that's right we wanted to we
wanted the findings to be airtight we
didn't want them to be skewed
uh a lot of things we turned up when we
did that when we studied 10 000 plus
millionaires
turned up what we thought was there
right
uh some of it more than we thought
um like i i mean uh tom stanley
uh i just did a quote for uh his
daughter sarah sent me an email this
week
they're doing an article on him i wrote
the millionaire next door there's some
folks at georgia university or georgia
state university or university of
georgia one of the two are doing
a series on tom which they should he was
iconic wonderful man
but he did the book in 1992 the
millionaire next door
and the the numbers we had always had
from that and from other studies that
were done
was that 70 to 75 of america's
millionaires were first generation rich
did not become millionaires because of
an inheritance
uh what we found was 79 received zero
inheritance that's right but we also
found two other things that
five percent uh the inheritance they
received was so small that it was
irrelevant they got a thousand dollars
or five thousand dollars or something
which is not zero but it did not cause
them and the other
that was five percent another five
percent did receive substantial monies
but it was after
they already were millionaires right uh
and so to
to say that none that now 93
is what we're now at uh of the people
that we studied
did not become millionaires
because of an inheritance correct
that's bizarre that's massively high
that's higher than we thought
that's much higher than i anticipated
and today zero
right no no one was caused that to
become a millionaire because of
inheritance and none of these now these
were over two million dollar net worth
they were five one 1.4 1.15
one point five one point three and one
yep and uh
uh 44 70 52 78 45 and
47 years old and the 401k was either
number one or number two
and i played all hearts of their
none of them had but one guy under a
three
and barely under a three uh gpa but none
of them had 4.0 nope
so we got social worker teachers sales
people
it's possible for you you got to believe
and then you need to work this is this
is why we do this we want you to believe
you can win because we know
you can the data says it that puts this
hour in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
you